Let's consider a more concrete case.
Consider some of the operating
systems we currently have or
had in case of MS-DOS and Vanguard.
So what exactly I said
in the OS portion and
the user portion of the address space,
how does it work in these systems?
So for example, if you look at the
address space layout for 32-bit Linux,
lower three gigabytes is where
the user code and data is going to go.
So address space is going to be
four gigabytes long, with 32 bits.
So we're going to separate that and
say one gigabyte for the kernel and
three gigabytes for the user.
The lower three gigabytes,
that's where the user code/data is.
The top one gigabyte is
where the kernel goes, and
there's this fence between these two.
The kernel portion can only be accessed
when you are in the operating system or
in the kernel.
Another thing to keep in mind is that
these portions of address space that we
have, access to those address spaces
also is related to what execution mode
or privilege ring you are in, so
x86 has the zero through three.
For you to be able to access the kernel
portion, you have to be entering zero or
in system mode if you are executing
user code in ring three, you can't
access this portion of the address space
that we have, which is the one gigabyte.
So this connects back the hardware
support that we have and
the address space like we
have been talking about.
So these other operating systems,
depending on what particular version,
may have some differences, but
typically this is how it works.
The operating system is common, so
this kernel one gigabyte has the same
data and code for every process, but
the three gigabyte is for
process, obviously.
This could be different for
different processes.
And we said, if you're executing this
part of this three gigabyte, then you
are in ring three, if you're executing
in the kernel, you are in ring zero.
This how operating systems manage access
to various part of the address space.
So modern operating
systems actually separate
the trusted computing
base from untrusted.
It wasn't always like that.
If you look at MS-DOS, and actually
now it's in a museum, Microsoft even,
the first version they made before is
called Available, actually, written in
assembly language, it didn't have
the separation that we're talking about.
There's no sort of fence or
wall between the user and
system code, so any process could
actually alter the operating system,
because you can freely march
down into the OS space.
And if you happen to be virus, you
obviously could hook anything, including
here, DOS interrupt handlers actually
are always in the operating system.
We are talking about dealing
with hardware device,
and direct access to hardware it
through privilege instructions,
not from user level, those
instructions have to be privileged.
Though, here you could actually change
the kernel, change the interrupt
handlers, there was no protection
that modern operating systems provide
through this isolation of the operating
system from application code